rise and shine come on up again  I'll go along melanin class once upon a  time there was a woman the most  beautiful and amazing woman in all the  world you just touch stuff watch no  please don't do that there are only  children one day she was attacked by a  monster but then a girl came anyway  and cubed and the women said you are my  special girl  she saved me and you're still afraid of  it yeah and you should be too I am  producing a vaccine and she is the main  ingredient  what's her lung  pipe that's what you bar I just want to  live everyone stuff  sure hope you  how is this the world is falling apart  what can save people Melanie everybody  why did you do the soul of our country  is at stake the purge targets the poor  and the innocent the center is going to  win it's going to make real changes to  it is a night that is